[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 2 mars voici le programme de ce
soir quelles sont les informations à
retenir dans le département aujourd'hui
au Salon International de l'Agriculture
les Yvelines ont remporté 18 médailles
qui sont les lauréats nous faisons le
point avec notre journaliste Régine
ralech côté sport le Football Club de
Versailles recherche un nouveau stade en
cas de montée en Ligue 2 quels sont les
stades évoqués c'est à découvrir dans
notre module les infos du jour à l'âge
de 17 ans livelinois marque le
Bouteiller et champion de France junior
et champion du monde de foot freestyle
il s'agit d'une discipline artistique et
sportive qui consiste à réaliser des
figures avec un ballon de football
originaire de Voisins-le-Bretonneux et
il commencé à s'exercer à l'âge de 12
ans comment a-t-il commencé comment
réaliser ses figures nous lui poserons
la question c'est notre invité et puis
comme d'habitude le jeudi à l'approche
du week-end nous vous donnerons nos
idées de sortie dans les Yvelines au
programme accrobranche Paris Nice et
festival pour les amateurs de jeux de
plateau nous partirons aussi à la
découverte d'un nouveau bar à jeux de
société qui vient d'ouvrir ses portes au
Mureaux et enfin nous ferons le point
sur un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer le
week-end prochain il s'agit du salon Art
et dégustation 80 exposants sont
attendus les détails avec
l'organisatrice Sandrine Montaigu et en
plateau avec moi une journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 c'est une Charles
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde alors vous
allez reprendre les idées de sortie de
Gabriel Gonthier vous allez nous parler
de quoi ce soir alors entre autres ce
soir je vous parlerai de sport bien
évidemment que le Paris-Nice une belle
sortie nature avec les chouettes et puis
aussi de jolis spectacles et donc ce
sera enfin démission restez bien avec
nous avec nous également à Tiz barré
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde alors vous êtes
conseiller municipal en charge du
bien-être animal pour la ville de Poissy
vous êtes en vous êtes venus en tenue
d'apiculteur vous allez nous parler de
quoi ce soir j'avais des frelons
asiatiques la protection des abeilles et
donc ce sera dans quelques instants
restez bien avec nous nous sommes aussi
avec le champion de français junior et
champion du monde de foot freestyle
marque le Bouteiller bonsoir alors tout
simplement pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de vous lancer dans le foot
freestyle voilà c'est très simple au
départ j'ai commencé par faire du foot
et puis sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai
commencé à trouver des vidéos qui
faisaient avec des gens qui faisaient du
freestyle football j'ai tout de suite
accroché et c'était une période où
j'étais blessé au foot donc c'était une
manière de remplacer le foot pour moi et
depuis j'ai jamais lâché et
devenu ma grande patience et vous allez
nous faire une petite démonstration tout
à l'heure
on a hâte de voir ça du coup ce soir
nous sommes aussi avec Sandrine Montaigu
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde alors vous êtes
l'organisatrice du salon Art et
dégustation qui se tiendra le week-end
prochain les 11 et 12 mars à
l'hippodrome de Rambouillet alors à quoi
doivent s'attendre les Yvelinois qui
veulent se rendre sur place alors à une
rencontre avec les producteurs locaux et
régionaux et puis un espace artisanat et
artiste puis des animations donc on en
parlera plus en détail tout à l'heure
dans notre page loisirs mais avant je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera encore bien
dégagé quelques nuages à prévoir mais
nous aurons tout de même de belles
éclaircies au niveau des températures
comptées 1 degré sur l'ensemble des
Yvelines dans l'après-midi le soleil
brillera toujours dans le département
côté température il fera 8 degrés vers
ou dans Rambouillet et Versailles et
comptez 9 degrés dans le secteur de
Mantes-la-Jolie et demain nous fêterons
la saint Gwénolé le point maintenant sur
l'actualité dans les Yvelines avec
Régine ralech
le Salon de l'Agriculture internationale
se termine ce dimanche 5 mars et les
amoureux du territoire yvelinois ont
récolté une pluie de récompense sur 57
médailles 18 ont été remportés par des
producteurs des Yvelines on note
notamment la brasserie barge à
Rambouillet qui reçoit la médaille
d'argent pour sa bière blanche la ferme
de Viltain a Jouy-en-Josas récolte une
médaille d'or pour son yaourt au lait de
vache brassé à la vanille ou encore la
pour le producteur de Rome square box au
Mureaux le club de football de
Versailles cherche un nouveau stade en
cas de montée en Ligue 2 arrivé en
National l'été dernier le FC Versailles
évolue actuellement à Jean Bouin mais la
pelouse synthétique du stade parisien ne
correspond pas aux normes de la deuxième
division professionnelle face à ces
difficultés les dirigeants Versailles
réfléchissent à une solution de repli
l'équipe pourrait être amenée à ce
délocaliser en dehors de la région
parisienne les stades du Mans et de
Villeneuve-d'Ascq sont par exemple
évoqués pour accueillir les joueurs la
mairie de Houdan met en vente 30 places
de stationnement situé rue de la Tour et
pris se situe entre 14000 et 16000 euros
les recettes de cette vente serviront
ont remboursement du pré relais de 1,4
millions d'euros contractés en novembre
dernier par la mairie les futurs
acquéreurs ont jusqu'au 1er avril pour
s'inscrire la vente se fera au tirage au
sort
[Musique]
et comme d'habitude si vous voyez une
information ou une image qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager en utilisant le hashtag
7 8 news
[Musique]
et c'est l'heure de passer à notre
chronique sur les animaux c'est avec
vous à Tiz barré alors ce soir vous
allez nous parler des frelons asiatiques
c'est devenu un véritable fléau pour nos
apiculteurs exactement Mathilde donc ce
soir on va parler du frelon à asiatique
pour protéger en fait nos abeilles en
fait les frelons asiatiques sont devenus
un véritable danger pour les hommes mais
également pour les insectes puisque les
frelons asiatiques consomment énormément
d'insectes et ils vont également manger
des abeilles donc le but ce soir est de
donner des gestes simples pour protéger
les abeilles puisque la menace est
double le frelon asiatique donc là on
est sur la période où il va sortir de
l'hibernation au mois d'août une fois
que son nid sera complètement construit
il va être difficile de lutter contre le
frelon asiatique qui se nourrit en fait
un nid se nourrit de 1 kg d'insectes
donc c'est énorme donc c'est un danger
pour la biodiversité également donc pour
les abeilles puisque les abeilles vont
être attendus à la sortie des ruches par
les frelons asiatiques qui vont aller
les attaquer pour aller les manger on
dirait que je parle d'un film d'horreur
mais c'est la réalité donc voilà et puis
du coup les butineuses bon bah elle va
elles vont avoir peur de sortir et donc
les le miel va se faire de plus en plus
rare alors comment différencier le
frelon asiatique du frelon européen
alors ça c'est une bonne question parce
que c'est difficile de faire la
différence entre les deux et c'est très
important pour protéger nos ruches alors
le frelon asiatique il est plus petit il
mesure 3 cm il a une tête qui est orange
avec un anneau orange au niveau du
thorax il pilule plus vite et il mange
beaucoup plus que le frelon européen
pilule ça veut dire qu'il bat des ailes
plus vite non ça veut dire qu'ils font
qui va pondre faire des naissances plus
plus rapidement et au niveau du frelon
européen donc lui il est un peu plus
grand il 4 cm il est brun il a donc un
thorax avec un anneau orange et des
pâtes brunes au niveau également de
l'Habitat vous pouvez faire la
différence avec le nid du frelon
asiatique il a des écailles celui du
frelon européen c'est en forme d'icône
l'entrée du nid du frelois asiatique
elle est plus petite et elle est exposée
en lumière et celui du frelon européen
lui plus dans les greniers au niveau des
endroits sombres et j'ai même étudié
donc leur comportement leur psychologie
le frelon asiatique lui donc il va être
il va être plus féroce il va attaquer
plus rapidement que le frelon européen
n'est plus pacifique il va attaquer
uniquement en cas de danger alors vous
le disiez juste à l'instant c'est c'est
un vrai un véritable fléau pour nos
apiculteurs c'est un problème pour eux
oui tout à fait donc si les apiculteurs
qui tirent la sonnette d'alarme j'ai
aussi Delmotte c'est un apiculteur de
Carrières-sous-Poissy qui est venu me
voir sur aussi il est actuellement au
ski il m'a prêté sa tenue donc il m'a
donc donné également c'est ses pièges
pour nous initier à des gestes très
simples avec quelques gestes on peut
sauver les abeilles donc là vous avez
par exemple un piège ou le l'abeille
elle pourra rentrer et sortir alors que
le frelon asiatique lui va être coincé à
l'intérieur ça c'est un piège qui coûte
environ 30 euros sinon on a des méthodes
un peu plus simple vous avez le bouchon
tout ça ça coûte environ un euro 50 ou
alors vous avez la méthode de la
bouteille que vous fabriquez votre piège
vous-même vous coupez donc la bouteille
en deux avec le bouchon on met à
l'intérieur du vin blanc du jus de
cassis et donc on va pallier à cette
attaque du frelon asiatique qui va se
retrouver piégé à l'intérieur et donc si
on retrouve un nid de frelons asiatique
près de chez nous qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire on utilise ces pièges mais est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres choses à faire on
fait appel à un professionnel surtout on
va pas soi-même s'attaquer au niveau du
nid donc si c'est au niveau de votre rue
donc vous appelez votre mairie elle va
faire appel à un professionnel si c'est
dans votre habitation n'hésitez pas à
contacter votre assureur votre assurance
habitation parce que les pompiers ne se
déplacent plus maintenant pour les nid
de guêpes donc vous allez peut-être des
garanties au niveau de vos garanties
assistantes au niveau de vos contrats
l'intervention sera pris en charge et
alors juste ces pièges où est-ce qu'on
doit les placer alors l'ennemi en fait
il se forme au niveau de la taille de
l'homme donc vous pouvez les disposer au
niveau des arbres ou alors au sol si
vous avez constaté la présence d'Annie
sur une année auparavant vous placez le
piège à côté puisque les fondatrices
vont revenir après des premiers ni merci
beaucoup à this pour tous vos merci à
vous pour les gestes pour la
biodiversité je suis également venue
avec un petit peu de miel si vous
souhaitez le goûter de notre apiculteur
de l'apiculteur voilà et c'est quoi
comme miel alors celui-là c'est mon
préféré c'est le miel de châtaigne de
châtaignes
on va goûter ça alors miel de châtaigne
il a un petit peu dur
si vous voulez
[Rires]
il est très bon ce miel et ben voilà il
faut continuer à respecter le travail
des apiculteurs
c'est bon pour les sportifs
pour la santé exactement et donc Cathy
sont vos retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle chronique sur les
animaux donc la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle chronique je serai en
présence d'un lapin d'un lapin
vous allez nous parler de quoi du coup
je bah c'est l'année du Lapin également
donc je vais vous parler un petit peu de
la psychologie des lapins et je vais
vous ramener un lapins qui devait être
abandonné dans une forêt et qui a été
recueillie par une famille psychée
allez c'est là maintenant de passer à
notre page loisirs
[Musique]
on va parler de football à présent mais
pas de n'importe quel football de
freestyle football la marque le
Bouteiller vous êtes originaire de
Voisins le bretonneux et vous avez
commencé à pratiquer cette discipline à
l'âge de 12 ans aujourd'hui vous avez 17
ans et vous êtes champion de France
junior et champion du monde de foot
freestyle alors vous nous avez un petit
peu expliqué comment est-ce que vous
étiez lancé dans cette discipline mais
pourquoi est-ce que ça vous a autant plu
alors ça m'a plu parce que c'était un
sport complètement individuel et donc ma
progression dépendait que de moi donc et
puis j'ai toujours été très fan de foot
ça s'en rapproché beaucoup j'ai toujours
aimé jongler quand je pratiquais le
football et quand j'ai vu des gens plus
expérimentés que moi j'ai tout de suite
voulu refaire pareil et au fil du temps
j'ai commencé à progresser un petit peu
et au fil du temps je voulais toujours
plus toujours plus et depuis ça s'est
jamais arrêté et du coup on peut dire
que maintenant
jouer un niveau professionnel alors si
on veut oui puisque mon sport est en
plein développement donc c'est
professionnel ou amateur la différence
est très petite donc je pratique je fais
beaucoup d'heures tous les jours donc je
pratique comme quelqu'un comme n'importe
quel sportif de haut niveau donc on peut
dire ça que je suis professionnel et
vous avez participé à deux grandes
compétitions du coup championnat de
France junior des moins de 16 ans et le
Championnat du Monde comment est-ce que
vous avez vécu ces expériences alors les
championnats de France en juniors ça a
été c'était une très belle expérience
j'ai eu une longue préparation pour être
préparée mentalement et et
psychologiquement et puis physiquement
j'avais
compétitions là comment on se prépare et
ben c'est un peu comme tout on répète on
répète on répète et voilà se prépare je
répète beaucoup mais gestes je prends
toutes les mesures possibles j'observe
mes adversaires pour voir
pour essayer d'être le moins surpris
possible et voilà on va dire que vous
avez un 7 prédéfini dans votre dans
votre mémoire et puis vous le faites
vous faites les figures les enchaîner et
alors est-ce qu'il y a une figure qui
est plus compliquée plus compliquée
qu'une autre alors il y a des figures
qui sont beaucoup plus compliquées que
d'autres après tout dépend quand on les
maîtrise ça devient facile mais en
particulier surtout avec le stress la
pression les enjeux qui peut y avoir et
le public qui regarde
il y a des figures qui deviennent deux
fois plus compliquées deux fois plus
compliqué qu'elle entraînement mais
sinon les figures les plus compliquées
c'est celle où il y a des roulades ou
des acrobaties comme le salto arrière ou
salto avant la figure de la plus
difficile la prendre pour vous ça a été
oui c'est un milieu il y a beaucoup de
compétitions il y a beaucoup de
football freestyler alors en France il y
a pas tant que ça il faudrait un peu
plus de monde mais mais on est déjà
assez nombreux un petit peu et voilà il
y a beaucoup de compétitions il y en a
pas beaucoup en France mais à
l'international il y en a et il y a de
quoi faire et du coup dans ces
compétitions est-ce qu'il y a des règles
à suivre enfin il y a des notations
enfin comment ça se passe alors il y a
plusieurs formats de compétition mais le
plus classique c'est les battles donc ça
va être des battles donc principalement
on va avoir deux personnes donc un
contrat et ça va être trois passages de
30 secondes et voilà et il y a 5 juges
qui déterminent qui a gagné en fonction
de certains critères et notamment le
style et les erreurs et la difficulté
des gestes est-ce que vous aimeriez
voir le le football freestyle aux Jeux
Olympiques un jour
c'est un grand grand rêve et justement
du coup on parlait un peu des
compétitions dans lesquelles vous avez
est-ce que vous avez d'autres objectifs
enfin vous souhaitez atteindre d'autres
objectifs alors oui j'ai quelques
objectifs j'aimerais beaucoup être
champion de France
l'année dernière j'ai je suis arrivé
troisième donc maintenant j'aimerais
vraiment pouvoir
aller jusqu'au titre et après pourquoi
pas grappiller quelques places sur le
plan européen et sur le plan mondial
faire les meilleures performances
possible le niveau est élevé en France
en France le niveau est très élevé ça
augmente constamment et c'est pareil
pour l'international du coup il y a une
véritable communauté autour de cette
discipline alors il y a une grande
communauté en France entre freesteller
on se connaît à peu près tous ou presque
et à l'international il y a également
une grande communauté donc il y a des
freestyler un petit peu partout dans le
monde et
voilà il y a des événements auxquels on
peut se regrouper chaque année et c'est
une communauté qui est vraiment géniale
et c'est un monde vraiment génial
est-ce qu'on peut ça ressemble
finalement plus au skate ou au break
exactement
comme le break sauf que c'est avec un
ballon donc oui qui est différent aussi
je sais pas peut-être un peu plus sport
de rue ou oui oui c'est vraiment un
sport où on a besoin que d'un ballon
pour pratiquer donc où qu'on soit on
peut on peut le pratiquer il suffit d'un
ballon et on peut faire ça avec qui on
veut ou on veut et voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez nous faire une petite
démonstration j'avoue que j'ai très
envie de voir comment est-ce que vous
vous débrouillez je vous laisse aller
tranquillement sur le petit plateau
qu'on a préparé pour vous juste derrière
on va vous mettre une petite musique
pour vous mettre dans l'ambiance
[Musique]
c'est presque artistique bah oui c'est à
la jonction entre le sport et
l'artistique justement
faut beaucoup d'équilibre aussi j'ai
l'impression
qu'il est déjà entendu parler de cette
discipline le football freestyle pas du
tout pas du tout et vous Sandrine
merci beaucoup Marc le Bouteiller
accepter notre invitation et puis pour
cette superbe démonstration merci on va
passer à un autre sujet à présent le
week-end prochain du 11 au 12 mars
exactement se déroule la deuxième
édition du salon Art et dégustation à
l'hippodrome de Rambouillet pour en
parler avec nous Sandrine Montaigu vous
êtes l'organisatrice de cet événement
vous attendez 80 exposants alors
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait retrouver sur
place alors
tout simplement des producteurs locaux
et régionaux
donc là on est dans le côté saveur et
dégustation évidemment on va pouvoir
acheter aussi
ils viendront de quelle région ces
producteurs de toute la France toute la
France toute la France alors après on a
quand même des personnes
qui sont dans la vallée de Chevreuse
mais qui vont nous proposer des des
plats sénégalais ou vietnamiens enfin on
va quand même un petit peu parcourir le
monde c'est aussi un petit c'est sympa
aussi donc il y aura de la dégustation
mais aussi de l'artisanat au niveau de
l'artisanat qui est ce qu'on pourra
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir alors
côté artisanat on va avoir l'art de la
table avec de la vaisselle des de la
céramique et puis aussi
des sacs voilà là des bijoux enfin côté
artisanat c'est un peu plus
éventail un peu plus grand voilà puis
des artistes aussi voilà il y aura aussi
une partie art vraiment ah alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut retrouver peintre
artiste sculpteur et musiciens voilà il
va y avoir deux concerts le samedi le
dimanche celui du samedi sera plutôt pop
rock voilà 14h30 et le dimanche à 15h
alors là on est dans la musique du monde
avec une musicienne
renommée qui va nous amener des petits
instruments ethniques voilà
c'est voilà c'est une belle découverte
un peu musique du monde électro c'est
sympa et puis au niveau artistique on
pourra aussi voir des puisque j'assimule
aussi un peu à l'art c'est à dire des
des enfants qui vont venir d'une école
de cirque donc là il va y avoir jonglage
diabolo
[Musique]
d'activités différentes ça se mélange
bien du coup la dégustation avec
déjà alors l'art se mélange avec tout
quand on aime l'art ouais moi je
l'associe à tout tout mes salons puisque
j'en organise quatre parents et quatre
thèmes différents et j'associe l'art à
chaque fois et alors vous nous avez un
petit peu parlé des animations qui
seront présentes il y a aussi des
ateliers alors il va pas y avoir
d'atelier puisque c'était prévu mais ça
a été annulé au dernier moment donc flop
c'est pas grave par contre il va y avoir
des promenades à la poney pour les
enfants aussi un espace jugé en bois
aussi pour les enfants
voilà au niveau animation on s'arrêtera
là parce que l'hippodrome n'est pas non
plus n'a pas non plus une surface
immense donc
on va déjà bien le remplir comme ça donc
c'est un événement pour pour tout le
monde en fait pour la famille c'est tout
public c'est tout public c'est la
famille et pour les animations pour
petits il va y avoir aussi un espace
restauration avec des food truck
divers au niveau choix en fait on va
dire ça vous tente autour du plateau
Céline marquatis oui
pourquoi pas
qu'est-ce qu'on pourra manger du coup
sur place plein de choses qu'est-ce
qu'on pourra déguster alors déguster il
va y avoir
alors tout le côté
producteur il y a un producteur Corse il
y a on a un producteur
du Jura avec son fromage
cette tête ça intéresse Céline dommage
elle aime beaucoup le salon de
l'agriculture n'est plus près de chez
moi ça m'intéresse
voilà il va y avoir aussi tout ce qui
est vin spiritueux
et puis le côté sucré caramel biscuits
voilà il y a un choix qui est quand même
pas mal je pense qu'on va tous trouver
notre couple et vous attendez combien de
personnes environ alors là c'est la
bonne question surtout lui a pris covid
je pense 2000 3000 quand même ah bah oui
déjà l'année dernière on a fait un peu
plus de 2000 personnes
au dernier événement donc je pense que
je pense que là comme les gens
ressortent un peu plus donc j'espère
et bien merci beaucoup Sandrine
alors je le rappelle du coup ça se
passera le week-end du 11 et 12 mars
c'est la deuxième édition du salon Art
et dégustation à l'hippodrome de
Rambouillet si vous êtes intéressé
l'entrée et tu as 4 euros et c'est
gratuit pour les moins de 12 ans une
autre idée de sortie à présent un peu
plus au nord des Yvelines il se nomme la
carte à jouer et ouvert et a ouvert ses
portes mardi 14 février dans le
centre-ville des Mureaux il s'agit d'un
café et d'un bar aux petits aigrants
peuvent venir partager de bons moments
autour d'un jeu de société un projet
rendu possible grâce à l'opération ma
boutique a laissé le reportage de
Grégory canalet et de Céline Charles
à peine ouvert la carte à jouer fait ça
le comble à l'intérieur tout a l'air
d'un café classique à une exception près
ici la boisson n'est pas la vedette
sur l'île donc il va falloir en sauver
un maximum et pour en sauver un maximum
pour savoir les placer correctement sur
votre plateau entre collègues amis ou en
famille ici on joue jeu de plateaux
d'aventure ou de stratégie il y en a
pour tous les goûts de quoi ravir petit
et grands enfants et convivial
c'est amusant ce jeu là tout le monde
construit quelque chose donc il y a un
peu de la course en même temps souvent
on s'entend bien donc c'est bien avec
mes filles avec mes enfants
petits-enfants on a toujours fait des
jeux de société bonne soirée et c'est
des moments ensemble
et pouvoir jouer voilà de faire des
rencontres
partager surtout c'est des jeux qu'on a
pas chez nous forcément donc ça c'est
pas mal de pouvoir en découvrir des
nouveaux et d'avoir des personnes qui va
nous expliquer les règles assez
rapidement aussi c'est pas mal parce que
des fois on comprend pas totalement les
règles quoi l'idée vient du gérant Kevin
d'évex lauréat de l'opération ma
boutique a laissé en juin 2022 il a
obtenu ce local à loyer modéré il
souhaitait ouvrir un lieu d'échange et
de convivialité l'idée est venue du fait
que moi je suis passionné de jeux de
société depuis quelques années
et je me suis rendu compte que le jeu de
société était encore assez peu
accessible malheureusement que ce soit
pour des questions de connaissances de
connaissances des règles ou de
s'imaginer que le jeu de société c'est
pour les geeks ou les enfants on essaie
de vous présenter au maximum les règles
des jeux de société de vous conseiller
en fonction de ce qui vous convient de
ce que vous aimez de ce que vous n'aimez
pas
et ensuite donc on vous aide à installer
le jeu on vous propose quelque chose à
boire ou à grignoter compter de 3,50 € à
5,50 € pour accéder aux différentes
parties de la ludothèque le café est
ouvert du mardi au samedi le Time's Up
le code naams ou encore le dixit
n'auront donc plus de secret pour vous
et nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
Régine rallès bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
reprenez le quiz du jeudi ce soir vous
allez nous challenger sur quoi Régine je
vais vous changez sur le cyclisme et
pourquoi le cyclisme parce que ce
dimanche 5 mars démarre la course Paris
- Nice aussi surnommé la Course au
Soleil et je suis aussi à préciser que
ce quiz a été pensé par l'une des
journalistes de rédaction Mélanie poquet
qui est fan de ce film voilà alors je
sais qu'au tour de la table vous aimez
aussi faire du vélo donc ça ne devrait
pas être un souci pour vous de répondre
aux questions bah on va essayer de
répondre à vos questions en tout cas
juste un petit message pour les
personnes qui nous suivent sur les
réseaux sociaux n'hésitez pas également
à répondre aux questions en tout cas
tenter de répondre à ce quiz alors la
première question est la suivante depuis
quand la Course au Soleil Paris-Nice
s'élance-t-elle dans le département des
Yvelines vous avez trois options 2008
2010 ou 2012
moi je dirais 2010
[Musique]
2008 2008 2010 Mathilde
et la bonne réponse est 2010
on a je note bien un point pour Céline
un point pour Mathilde alors depuis 2010
la course avait été lancée à
Montfort-l'Amaury et c'était le cours le
cours néerlandais Lars Boom qui avait
remporté le prologue et la course avait
été remporté par l'Espagnol Alberto
Contador alors la deuxième question en
2019 la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
des cerne un prix au département
savez-vous lequel vous avez également
trois options terre d'excellence
cycliste département d'excellence
cyclistes ou territoire d'excellence
cyclistes alors moi je pense que j'ai la
réponse je vous laisse tirer la première
oui moi aussi j'irai la première terre
d'excellence département Territoire
tout le monde a juste alors je vais
mettre un point pour tout le monde
félicitations à vous
super super alors félicitations à vous
donc le label terre d'excellence
cycliste il valorise l'offre local de
cyclisme en matière d'espace de pratique
et augmente la tractivité et la
visibilité du territoire et reconnaît de
des potentiels organisateurs
d'événements sportifs alors la question
suivante combien de kilomètres de
circulation douce ont été réalisées par
le département des Yvelines vous avez
également trois options
850 km
1000 km ou 600 km
[Musique]
850 km je pense parce que j'aurais dit
600 mais je crois que c'est un petit peu
augmenté donc 850 les autres
participants
[Musique]
la course encore donc très bonne réponse
c'est exactement 850 km qui ont été
comptabilisés en 2016 et c'est depuis
2006 que les départements mènent une
politique pour justement favoriser ces
circulations donc on retrouve beaucoup
de circulation douce sur les routes
départementales les voies vertes et
forestières nous passons à
l'avant-dernière question je trouve que
vous êtes plutôt fort aujourd'hui on a
bien révisé voilà
alors la prochaine question donc il est
maire de sa commune depuis 2012 il est
aussi directeur de la communication de
la Fédération française de cyclotourisme
savez-vous de qui je parle
j'essaie de reconnaître la mairie qui
est caché derrière la petite animation
ça peut être un indice je pense que
c'est la mairie de Magny-les-Hameaux
très bien il y a maniyamoki Bertrand
Houillon magnifique
nous passons à la dernière question
j'espère que certains d'entre vous
pourront se remettre en scène j'ai
préparées
se dérouleront les épreuves cyclistes
dans le département à l'occasion des
Jeux Olympiques alors attention c'est
plus difficile il y a des épreuves sur
piste des épreuves BMX sur route ou en
VTT
[Musique]
très bonne réponse on a le vélo de route
et le BMX aussi
oui
ça sera en Vallée de Chevreuse donc je
répète juste les réponses donc sur piste
le vélo de route nationale BMX Stadium
du vélo drone sur route en vallée de
cheveux et VTT collines d'Élancourt vous
êtes vraiment excellente aujourd'hui les
filles ça après les épreuves aux Jeux
Olympiques on le dit assez quand même
assez souvent dans les Yvelines donc ça
va en tout cas pour marketis il va
falloir se remettre en scène on fait du
ballon
merci beaucoup Régine rallès pour ce
quiz on en apprend on va toujours un peu
plus sur les Yvelines grâce à vous merci
en parler juste avant de Paris Nice du
coup céline est justement vous commencez
vos idées de sortie par cette course
mythique Paris Nice exactement et le
débat le départ est programmé ce
week-end depuis les Yvelines à la
verrière et c'est notre journaliste
Michael et le midoro qui nous a fait un
point sur l'événement
le Paris-Nice partira ce week-end depuis
les Yvelines pour la 14e fois
consécutive ce dimanche 5 mars les
coureur partiront de la verrière pour
une boucle de 169,4 km dans les Yvelines
une grande première pour la vie les 6000
habitants de la commune de 50 ans en
Yvelines pourront voir des sportifs de
haut niveau comme le vainqueur du
dernier Tour de France fionase Wingard
il y aura également étéage poggatchard
vainqueur de deux tours de France il y
aura des Français comme Romain Bardet ou
encore Arnaud démarre le départ sera
donné à 13h depuis la mairie au niveau
organisation un village sur Installer
dès le samedi 4 mars de 10 heures à 18h
au parc sportif Philippe Cousteau il y
aura des animations autour du cyclisme
le jour J la circulation sera très
perturbé dans la commune vous ne pourrez
pas circuler dans le centre de 6 heures
à 20h et il est vivement recommandé de
se garer du côté du parking de la
Commanderie les bus des équipes seront
installés devant le quartier du Bois de
l’étang le lendemain c'est la petite
commune de Bazainville qui accueillera
les sportifs ce sera là aussi une grande
première les sportifs partiront à 13h
direction à Fontainebleau
et nous serons présents pour les deux
premières étapes de l'épreuve Parisis
Céline vous allez maintenant nous parler
d'une autre activité qui est un peu plus
sportive oui à vie aux petits et grand
aventuriers adepte d'accrobranche les
parcs à croquantes des Yvelines vous
accueille pendant les vacances scolaires
d'hiver il vous reste donc samedi
dimanche pour enfiler votre baudrier et
aller crapahuter dans les arbres
tyrolienne pont de singe saut de tarzan
différents parcours vous attendent de 10
heures à 19h dans le département vous
avez deux choix le parc de Poissy et
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la réservation est
néanmoins conseillée on poursuit avec
une autre activité Céline qui va
peut-être vous intéresser si vous êtes
breton et oui Mathilde ça va parler aux
fans de musique celtique ou tout
simplement des curieux le cercle
celticle de Poissy organise la 53e
édition de son traditionnel fast nose
alors un fest-noz c'est quoi c'est tout
simplement un rassemblement festif basé
sur la pratique collective des danses
traditionnelles bretonnes accompagnées
de chants ou de musique instrumental
alors celui-ci se déroulera ce samedi 4
mars au centre de diffusion artistique
de Poissy à partir de 20h30 plusieurs
groupes se succéderont durant la soirée
le prix d'entrée d'entrée et de 10 euros
on continue avec un spectacle équestre
Céline cette fois-ci tout à fait en
poursuit avec ce spectacle magnifique à
la grande écurie du château de
Versailles l'Académie équestre vous
présente la voie de l'écuyère
chorégraphié par bar-tabac durant une
heure environ vous pourrez observer la
nouvelle promotion des cuillères
évoluées sur des chorégraphies inédites
et revisités les tableaux emblématiques
de l'Académie un mélange de plusieurs
disciplines qui au dos escrime chant le
spectacle a lieu le samedi 4 et le
dimanche 5 réservation conseillée
également et on termine par une chouette
sortie nature Céline alors durant tout
le mois de mars nous célébrons la 15e
édition de la Nuit de la chouette
organisée par la Ligue pour la
Protection des Oiseaux beaucoup
d'événements sont organisés en France et
c'est le cas samedi 4 mars au Chesnay
Rocquencourt à partir de 17h des
ateliers et chants sont animés par un
groupe de cinq étudiants de l'Institut
supérieur de l'environnement de
Versailles un repas est également prévu
à 18h30 pour les plus intéressés et les
aides de la nuit vous invite également à
les accompagner à partir de 19h à la
forêt de fosses repose pour une sortie
nocturne vous pourrez peut-être
apercevoir des chouettes si vous êtes
chanceux mais attention le nombre de
places est également limité merci
beaucoup Céline pour ces idées de sortie
alors comme d'habitude petit tour de
plateau qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous
intéresse le plus ce soir
la sortie pour les oiseaux oui
évidemment ça parle d'animaux du coup
ce serait le fils nos yeux vous avez des
origines bretelles
et vous Marc
équestre ça m'étonne pas d'équitation
donc et vous Céline du coup vous allez
aussi grande fan de musique celtique
donc
vous retrouverez au fait nos crêpes
aussi
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant je tourne un dernier
coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera encore bien
dégagé quelques nuages à prévoir mais
nous aurons tout de même de belles
éclaircies au niveau des températures
comptées 1 degré sur l'ensemble des
Yvelines dans l'après-midi le soleil
brillera toujours dans le département
côté température il fera 8 degrés vers
ou dans Rambouillet et Versailles et
compter 9 degrés dans le secteur de
Mantes-la-Jolie et Céline quel temps
fera-t-il ce week-end un week-end assez
nuageux dans l'ensemble du département
Mathilde samedi matin le temps sera
couvert partout dans les Yvelines
comptées entre 4 et 5 degrés pour les
températures on retrouve la même
tendance nuageuse l'après-midi les
températures seront cependant légère
hausse il fera 7 degrés partout sur le
territoire dimanche matin pas de
différence des nuages sur l'ensemble du
département et des températures allant
de 4 à 5 degrés en revanche que les
coureurs du Paris-Nice soient rassuré le
soleil devrait pointer le bout de son
nez dans l'après-midi prévoyez tout de
même de quoi vous couvrir il fera 6
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et
Versailles les 5 degrés à Rambouillet
merci beaucoup Céline une dernière
information avant de se quitter chaque
samedi TV 78 vous propose de recevoir
directement dans votre boîte mail un
résumé de l'actualité des Yvelines
société politique économie mais aussi
loisirs culture et sport vous
retrouverez tous les événements
marquants de la semaine écoulés avec les
liens vers nos reportages et interviews
pour vous inscrire vous pouvez vous
rendre à l'adresse internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran ou
flashé notre
QR code n'hésitez pas à nous contacter
sur
rédaction@tv 78.com pour nous faire part
de vos retours et de vos attentes
surtout et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]